e
e e
good morning everyone welcome to Jael
car I see we do have a
quum if someone who was at the previous
meeting could discuss the
minutes I will to accept second all
right any discussion on the
minutes all right those in favor I I I
will abstain because I was to the last
meeting
all right uh alternates we've got
me don't need very many alternates I'm
Chanley in a ward all right we are all
regular members congratulations on our
attendance time it is it's kind of
random who you'll get okay the consent
agenda does anyone have something to
come off the consent
agenda during then during then I move
adoption of the consent agenda uh
director moral um there are two items on
the regular agenda that are placed there
mistakenly they should be on the consent
agenda the first is 202
24-5
exf the other is 2024
105 both of those are on the agenda they
they are on the on the um consent agenda
on yes they are on the paper one but uh
if if you look at the meeting packets
they are not okay right those are the
ones that we decided the last minute
work should be on consent so if anyone
is
confused see director
moral all right any discussion of the
consent
agenda all right hearing none those in
favor I I those
opposed all right consent to agenda is
adop representative SCH
any PI somebody I heard I heard Peter so
all right regular the installation
Standards
Board all right so the reason this is on
the regular agenda is because the rules
are expired they expired in um 4 of
22 and PLC
10223 didn't take effect until August of
23 so there was a big gap in between um
the expired rules and the new fee rules
um so J car may have questions about
fees that may have been
um collected yes we do have such a
question can you answer them Miss yes
Tina Kelly rules coordinator office of
professional Li Insurance certification
good morning um no fees were collected
during that time and no actions were
taken on any a leny or applicant
really for two years nobody applied and
and no discipline that is what I I asked
um the people from each of those
sections and that was what I was
communicated well that sounds like we
ought to look into whether we really
need that board if they can go for two
years with nobody uh lying dealing with
them I can't say whether or not anybody
applied what I can say is no fees were
collected no fees were collect ah okay
thank you that is simpler all right
thank you very much is there any other
questions or comments move to
approve okay moved by Senator Lang
seconded
by Senator Chanley in inis okay sorry
he's
hiding uh any further
discussion those in favor
any opposed all right thank you very
much thank
you all right Department of
energy so this is proposal 2024 28 it's
Energy 800 the underground utility
damage prevention program the agency did
file an amended conditional approval
which addressed all my substantive
comments however there is a note to the
committee regarding a reference to the
energy 200 rules those have not been
filed with our office yet um as of right
now my understanding is that the
department is using the Pu 200 rules
which they're allowed to do under RSA 12
p14 um however that statute only allows
the department to use any of their
existing rules until the rules expire
are repealed are amended Ed or a period
of 5 years has passed whichever occurs
first and our office did receive a
proposal from the Pu to amend their 200
rules so once that is adopted the
department of energy will no longer be
able to use those rules um so there is a
bit of a question about what rules they
will be using and how far out they are
of creating their own 200 rules I had a
very brief conversation with the agency
before the meeting and it sounds like
should the Pu rules be adopted before
any energy 200 rules are put into effect
um the agency will then rely on the
Justice 800 rules um but there's still a
question about how soon they will have
their own 200 rules in
place good morning good
morning uh you probably want to turn
your microphone on thank you good
morning uh my name is David shulock I'm
the general counsel at the department of
energy
um we do have a plan for adopting new
200 rules there is a substantial draft
already
done um and we intend to go to
stakeholder sessions uh in November
right uh and those would be informal
stakeholder sessions to make sure that
um our regulated Community um is not
adversely affected by the procedural
rules that we adopt we had originally uh
intended uh with the Pu to do these
rules later on right because um you know
we have many rule sets that we have to
adopt or revise and adopt um after the
reorganization uh and we we plotted
those out based upon expiration date
essentially and then you know the 800
rules were a matter of opportunity we
had an attorney who was able to to do
those rules those got moved ahead just a
little bit
um but everything is done by expiration
date and because the 200 rules didn't
expire those were planned to do later um
which would not have an adverse effect
on the regulated Community because
they're accustomed to using those rules
that's and actually changing them might
cause them a little bit more work uh
than than keeping them so uh we plan to
go to stakeholder sessions in in
November
okay any B pres bro do you have a
question I'm I'm kind of concerned
that if these These are the practice and
procedure rules correct that's correct
and from my limited understanding you
should be able to just take the Pu rules
change a few addresses and re and adopt
them as your rules because you're not
changing your practice the procedure
very much is that correct or am I
mistaken in
something well we we do have to make
some changes to the rules because in
the in the
reorganization some things were jointly
given to the two agencies some things
are given to both agencies and some
things are just given to one agency so
there's some sorting out to do okay fine
so it should take a little thinking to
to sort it out but other than that the
these should be the easiest rules for
you to
do um you you might think that but we
had rules that were going to expire and
we had to focus on those absolutely I
appreciate that and there there are over
20 rule sets right that we have to do
this for and and that's the order that
we're taking them in okay all right I I
could understand repres Senator Lang
thank you I maybe it's for the uh for
attorneys in the room but again my
question is I think you said 200's
expired or is not enforcable anymore and
yet the rules they're using are saying
that they have to do their hearings
pursuant to the rules that are expired
is that did I misunderstand something um
so right now they can use the pu2 200
rules they are not referenced in this
rule set they actually site to the
energy 200 rules not the PC 200 but
under the statute they can still use the
Pu 200 until pu reads their rules which
they are in the process of doing at the
moment um we have their initial proposal
already yeah and you know do that follow
up so again so the concern is we adopt
their 200 rules before they have their
200 rules ready for energy and now we
have a conflict of some sort right
because energy wouldn't be able to use
those anymore um so they would have to
either have their own rules in or uh the
Justice 800 rules are kind
of generic template generic procedural
rules that agencies can use um but there
are certain procedures that need to be
in place before they can use those so as
long as the department does that they
can then potentially use the Justice 800
rules in the meantime but once again yes
these rules still just site to the
energy 200 rules which are not don't
exist they're not in exist
this sounds like when we separated the
Departments the two departments did not
coordinate their rulemaking efforts so
um the two departments had very little
notice that there was going to be re a
reorganization if you remember it went
through the budget cycle and not through
the legislative uh cycle well aware of
that um uh after the reorganization we
did coordinate we we had uh meetings
with uh the Department of Justice with
represent representatives from the
Department for both uh uh Department of
energy and the Pu uh we worked out
schedules uh for uh doing the rules
basically on this by expiration date
schedule uh we do coordinate a great bit
so um the when we do a set of rules the
Department because it had more resources
um does a set of rules for the
department and a set of rules for the
commission we do all that basic work for
them um and then it goes to the
commission and the Department of Justice
to review to see whether we have
appropriately divided the rules based
upon the jurisdiction that we have under
the revised statutes right which is
actually the hardest part to figure out
right um and and uh then you know we
have proceeded to file our notices of
rulem at the same time for sets of rules
um the Pu for whatever reason decided to
move ahead with its 200 rules uh we've
asked them not to do that but they're
doing it anyhow uh the rules are a
little bit uh problematic for us in what
they've done because there are some
rules that we absolutely rely
on uh such as uh the probably the most
important one is their rule for waving
other rules right once once they amend
that uh which they planned to do uh we
would no longer be able to wave anything
which um is can be quite a hardship on
the regulated Community or a rate payer
when they're coming in for some relief
if we're not able to to wave a rule
appropriately so we have asked them not
to amend the the there's a there are a
number of rules that we absolutely rely
on and that don't exist anywhere El else
and uh they have agreed not to amend
those they're going to restructure their
rul making so that those are not uh
amended and reopt
it would that excuse me would that solve
the issue of them not having any rules
in place no no it will not so um they
they do plan to proceed on the uh
procedural rules for adjudications and
rul makings um and for those
that's where we would default to the
Justice rules but so but to to clarify
should the Pu pull those sections out of
their current proposal and not have them
changed in any way or just reopt it then
yes the department of eny could still
use those rules okay well then that's
thank you that sounds like an elegant
way of solving it if you've identified
specific ones that you need well it it
doesn't resolve every problem well um
the the the the new pu rules will have a
um fiscal impact on our agency um and so
we need to work that out with them as
well
lovely thank you so when do the Pu 200
rules expire and when does your your
group plan
on bringing your P your 200 rules to
Jael car is there is there an overlap or
so uh 200 rules don't actually expire
what will trigger rules of procedure
yeah um what will trigger our inability
to use them is when you actually approve
the rules and they're adopted at that
point we won't be able to utilize um the
any rules that are amended right all
right so is it possible then excuse me
follow up followup is it possible then
to wait for the Pu to
wait on their adoption of their rules
until this
group um gets their rules completed so
that we don't have that conflict so we
we have asked them to do that and
they've said
no uh but they have agreed to pull out a
few specific rules that you absolutely
need yes all right that that is a start
at
least
we'll we we'll blame the hurriedness of
the uh separation for for the
mess but um I do hope that you'll be
able to accelerate
the the writing of your own 200 rules so
this you don't have to rely on uh the Pu
leaving things
alone well we we did um schedule them in
advance of when we would have worked on
them but it it won't the stakeholder
sessions won't start until November all
right thank you but it was it was going
to be 2027 so so we we have moved them
up that's that's beyond my term of Duty
so all right move to
approve all right Senator Lang moves to
approve senator in seconds
representative brassy can sit in for
representative Lon who won't be
here any any discussion comments
questions those in favor I I those
opposed all right thank you very much
and good luck thank you
yeah okay Board of
Medicine so this is uh 2024 60 it's on
examination requirements for Physicians
and the only reason it is on the reg
regular agenda is because it is expired
in May of
2022 so there may be questions about how
these exams
were we're done good
morning good morning Shantel wheeler
rules administrator office of
professional lure and certification on
behalf of the Board of
Medicine say so how on Earth could you
let your rules be expired for two years
well that is a a question I'm not I
can't answer we I um director Courtney
has um mentioned before we have the new
software system so we are implementing
that we've been working with the boards
carefully to identify expiring rules and
start the ru making process um the
statutory requirements for exams for the
board of medicine is in RSA 32912 and
they rule applications excuse me have
been processed according to the
statute under
that Senator Lang the new rule is
basically the same as the old rule just
being reopt yes thank
you and I understand there's no fees in
this one so you don't have to worry
about that issue not this
time move to approve second all
right then move to approve any
discussion comments
questions those in favor I
opposed all right and when is your next
rule making starting on do you have any
other expired rules that's
see
yes and you are in the midst of rule
making on them I trust we are
yes all right well we'll see you again
I'm sure thank
you all right
the opioid abatement trust
fund all right so this is item 2024
112 um the agency did file a conditional
approval request which did address a
majority of my comments however I still
had one unclear comment on page three of
the conditional approval text regarding
the reports that need to be filed under
the statute it is required that the
applicants and government entities file
an annual report and that they do so by
September 1st of each year however the
way that this particular rule is written
it then goes on to say that the
department could require more frequent
submissions now there's not a question
that the department could require this
they can absolutely do so just the fact
that it's kind of put under the annual
report makes it a bit unclear
because the annual report is under the
statute the statute says annual so they
need different Authority in order to ask
for those different submissions and
additionally there was a question of how
frequent Is frequent they needed some
criteria to establish when exactly they
would be asking for additional reports
um the agency and I did have some
discussions and some draft language was
made um that I believe they're going to
orally amend their conditional approval
request uh with that language and if
they do so then that would address my
comment good morning good morning Alison
radme administrator for the
administrative rules unit at the
Department of Health and Human
Services good morning attorney Robin
guino I'm an attorney for the Department
of Health and Human Services um and that
is correct uh before uh coming in here
this morning uh we are all in agreement
uh there was two sets of proposed
language and um I know we have agreed on
that we're going to agree on set number
one uh which will split out the current
uh a as written um in into uh A and B
and kind of expand on b a little bit for
the additional uh
reports okay would you
uh read that to us so we can sure sorry
what you want want us to vote on it
absolutely uh okay so the new a will be
applicants in governmental entities
shall submit an annual report outlined
in RSA
126-a colon 84 IV I apologize I'm awful
with
Romans um to the department by September
1st of each year uh the new B will be if
the Department's rules Grant contracts
or memoranda of understanding require a
more frequent submission the applicants
and government entities shall submit a
the report a above more frequently than
once a year the department shall
determine the frequency of submission
based on compliance with the
Department's rules Grant contracts or
memoranda of understanding um and then
we will Rel relet uh the existing
paragraphs uh under the I do have a
concern that that allows you to ask them
to put that report in every week or
every day is what's your expected
frequency every quarter or every month
um thank you for asking that question uh
from a practical standpoint asking for
such a report every day or every week is
just more than the department I'm sure
can bear um I think that there is no
necess there's not necessarily an
anticipation of asking for reports at
this point more frequently than annually
just the idea of keeping the option open
because we may have Department may have
uh certain in um vendors who are
approved that they might want to keep a
closer eye on either because they're um
new to the market not necessarily has
have been in business quite a while I
can't see the department and again this
would be speculation on my part but I
can't see the department asking for
anything at the at the worst case
scenario more than monthly and I just
don't see that happening I think I think
more reasonably it might be by anually
and I and maybe even quarterly but I
don't even necessarily see that
happening with the weight that they
bear can you reread B for me sure okay
so B if the Department's rules Grant
contracts or memoranda of understanding
require a more frequent submission the
applicants and government entities shall
submit the report in a above more
frequently more frequently than once a
year the department shall determine the
frequency of submissions based on
compliance with the Department's rules
Grant contracts or memoranda of
understanding so the second half of that
sentence was the one I I was concern not
concerned with but I was trying to
understand again that talks about if you
have an issue with an a vendor whatever
that may be talks about whether they're
in compliance or not so you may have had
an issue with a vendor and this would
allow you to keep closer tabs on that
vendor that might have had a
disciplinary type of action and make
them keep their data up faster and
sooner so you don't have the problem go
on again
correct any other
questions move to
approve I'll second right move by
Senator Lang seconded by representative
Roa any comments or
questions all right so the motion is to
to condition conditionally approve the
conditional approval
request and uh those in favor
I those opposed all right thank you very
much and thank you for clarifying that
thank you so much okay all right the
last of our business is a emergency rule
also from Health and Human
Services which is a discussion item
other than there's the uh another
one
um this emergency rule came in last week
it relates to youth recreation camps um
dealing with RSA 126 U and
h901 uh it deals with restraints at
youth camps youth recreation camps
um there the statute forbids uh such
restraints for ordinary
uh camps but it does allow that for
State
facilities um the concern that I had
regarding this uh is what the emergency
is at this moment why is this different
from two months ago or last year uh
particularly given that there are only
probably a couple of weeks left in the
Camp
season yes good morning uh again Alison
radme the administrator for the
administrative rules unit of the
Department of Health and Human
Services good morning my name is Dorian
shley I'm the manager of the Bureau of
Licensing and certification at the
department and I appreciate the question
um it currently the youth recreation
program rules don't specify that
restraint and seclusion practices are
prohibited at camps so this emergency
rule will expressly prohibit that from
occurring uh we had received questions
from some of the youth camps if this
applied to them and we wanted to make
sure that they all knew they can't
restrain and seclude um we do have camps
that run all year round to the point
about them ending in a couple weeks we
have some that are spring some that are
summer some that are fall some that are
winter some that are all year round um
it's also important to note that we have
been working collaboratively with the
camps all year to um enter into regular
Ru making and this will also um they'll
have an opportunity during the regular
rule making for any public comments or
hearing that um because it'll be a
public hearing at that time we
anticipate submitting the final rules
probably in September so that when the
new um Camp season starts for the bulk
of the summer camps in May um it will
already be part of the regular Ru
making any other questions
comments director moral um
this requirement regarding restraints or
prohibition on restraints is already in
statute it's simply not the issue I
guess is it's simply not in the rules
and there may be some confusion among
Camp owners um but I'm not sure whether
that constitutes an emergency or not
which is up to the committee to decide
so if I may also add on to that so RSA
126 U and HC 901 does not include camps
so they're not part of the required
reporting that's would be schools and um
residential
youth Child Care residential facilities
but camps are not part of that
unless so the the question is that the
statute does not specifically include
Recreation camps and some of the camps
are concerned concerned that they might
not be able to no so let me try to so
right now camps want to know if they
have to report when they restrain and
seclude according to 126 U the point is
is they cannot restrain and seclude this
isn't about reporting they're not
trained um there's specific training
required in both of those statutes that
camps aren't trained to do we do not
want people staff at camps restraining
or secluding our youth that's why it's
an
emergency and there is no reporting
requirement since there is no action
that would require reporting correct
correct but currently there's nothing
that prohibits it so they could in fact
be restraining and secluding children
and not reporting it all right thank you
anyone else director um I would
have to disagree without uh regarding
there not being a statutory requirement
RSA 17 e
E34 Roman 1 I uh requires the
commissioner to adopt rules for
compliance with RSA 126 U regarding the
use of physical and medication
restraint so there is a statutory
requirement in place but I admit it's an
entirely different chapter and I can see
where people might not uh be aware of it
well but that doesn't say that the camps
can't seclude or restraint it simply
says the commissioner has to have rules
and they're trying to do
so is that I stand to be corrected but I
think 126 U
says one of the statutes says that um
restraints can only be used by state
entities I'm not familiar you mentioned
that earlier in your test I'm not
familiar with what you're referring to
there I'm sorry I okay that was a
surprise s again I I think this falls
under Public Safety right in general if
you're the kid that's getting restrained
you probably or Camp right you're
putting the at risk and I think knowing
what the rules are are very important
and granted it just came to light that
this didn't exist and it's important to
get it done while you while you go about
your regular rule making process so I'm
okay with this thank you you thank you
madam chair
um my uh understanding about the way
camps are regulated um is certainly
incomplete um but I do know at one time
this was the purview of um Dees and has
recently fairly recently become uh gone
under the uh consideration of
DHHS uh I think there probably a number
of questions that still are to be
answered perhaps there is it it it might
be necessary to look at this statutorily
at some point but I can live with this
um emergency rule at this point so thank
you for bringing this forward than you
anyone
else yeah I'd like to say that I'm
interested what will come out of the
regular rul making but uh I don't think
it can hurt anybody to clarify that they
are not to restrain or or seclude
children thank you very much all right
we don't have to take any action because
it's an emergency rule but we will look
forward to the uh
the permanent rle thank you all right
anything else oh yes the equalization
manual
letter
so the equalization manual from the
Department of Revenue Administration for
those committee members who were not
here in 2022 or just it was two years
ago so also just a
refresher the revenue 28 100 rules came
before the committee there was some
discussion about whether or not the
equalization
manual had to be incorporated or could
be incorporated by reference or had to
be in the rule text it was our office's
opinion that it needed to be in the rule
text and could not be incorporated
because it was a document that's
essentially made for the Department of
Revenue
Administration um by the assessment
board which is Administrative attached
it
essentially gives the department and
municipalities requirements on what to
do when they are doing uh an
equalization of uh property values so
during that
discussion it was agreed that trying to
put the requirements in the rule text
was very um difficult for the agency
because putting it out rule text it
wasn't in compliance with the manual
there would have been a lot of work
needed so at the time the committee
approved the rules with the
understanding that the department would
go and get a statutory exemption to
allow them to incorporate the manual by
reference in their rules which they did
however back in June I had a call from
the clerk of the New Hampshire Board of
tax and land appeals and she was
inquiring about the incorporation by
reference of the equalization manual in
Revenue
800 she could not get into the specifics
at that time because it was an ongoing
case before the board she just wanted to
know if we had an incorporation by
reference statement for that particular
uh rule set and I was able to explain to
her that we did not at that time because
the committee allowed them to move
forward and have it in their
rules before the statutory exemption
came but now that they have the
statutory exemption they're allowed to
incorporate reference
after uh a couple weeks uh end of July I
contacted the clerk again to see if the
board had issued an order because I was
curious and wanted to follow up on this
issue and she did send me the written
order that was uh given by the board of
tax and land appeal it was uh concerning
to me because the department essentially
took the position that the equalization
manual was not a rule and that they did
not have to strict comply with it when
doing this particular uh
Equalization in fact uh their director
of Municipal and property division is
quoted in the order saying the
equalization manual is not a statute is
not a rule it's a guideline for the
towns to use in the equalization process
with the
Dr rev
1.04 has
Equalization manual defined as the
approved uh the equalization manual as
approved by the New Hampshire assessing
Standards Board and revenue
28002010
j9a the department shall annually
determine the total Equalization
valuation of properties in accordance
with sections 1 3 and 8 of the manual
that's why we had the whole discussion
about whether or not this manual could
be Incorporation by reference because
it's specifically stated in the rules
that this manual is a requirement that
the department and municipalities have
to follow so now that this issue has
come to my attention I have concerns
that there is some um
misunderstanding about what rules are
and what the equal Equalization manual
is as a rule um so I drafted a letter to
the department on behalf of the
committee which essentially outlines the
committee's options that they could take
at this point in time to address this
issue should the committee be concerned
about it uh the first is that the
committee could um during the next
legislative session remove the statutory
exemption uh from statute and petition
the department to then enter rul making
to put it directly in their
rules uh the other requirement or the
other option for the Comm is that the
committee could adopt a statute that
simply says the equalization manual is
to be followed is you know the process
that needs to be followed so it's
statutory as opposed to rules and
therefore there's no question about
whether or not it needs to be
followed
um and uh the other uh
option is um to petition the department
without doing any
statutory uh changes to just make it
clearer that this is what needs to be
followed and done uh even though I don't
see how that that would take some some
thinking because it's pretty clear to me
that the rule says that well that's it
strikes me that the issue is that one
side of the Dr is saying the
equalization manual is in the rule and
you and we and and the T must follow at
least this part of it when we're doing
an equalization and another part is
arguing before the board of tax and land
appeals that oh no we don't have to
follow our rules and I think that's the
concern is that
the when
challenged they're not saying oh you
know you're right we need to follow our
own
rules and in which specifically include
the equalization manual they're they're
trying to get out of their own rules and
that that's something that is up to the
commissioner of the Dr to straighten
out uh so at least in my opinion so and
that's this draft letter could be a
first step um if the committee reviewed
it and wanted to send it to the
department to the commissioner directly
to notify them that we are aware of this
issue and we're concerned about this
issue and that should the issue not be
addressed further action may be taken
um as kind of a first step if you think
the commissioner would be able to um do
some internal enely within his
Department you know I mean his rules are
perfectly clear that they that the
agency has to follow these these parts
of the manual it's in their rules that
say
so but director moral I I would just
note that any material whether entire
document or portions of it that are
Incorporated by reference are
rules yes yes yes so the uh it sounds
like the Dr has a uh a rogue entity
that's out there you know suing being
sued by the towns for not following its
own rules and we ought to thank the town
well at molteno wasn't it it was yes for
not follow for bringing it to our
attention that the arrays not follow
following its own rules right so this
letter would would you know start the
process it would notify the commissioner
of Dr that there's a problem that that
the jail car is concerned with um we're
obviously not going to send that letter
until you guys agree that it's something
we should do but we think it's the next
step to to kind of put them on notice
like we we see what you're doing we see
that you're not following your rules and
that's not
acceptable anyone else
so representative Schmid thank you madam
chair so you have referred to it several
times as a draft letter but but by the
same token attorney mun has said that
the letter has been sent so no no no it
has not been sent no no no well if it
hasn't been sent did wasn't there just a
statement made that the commissioner has
been
notified the commissioner has not yet
been notified this letter will notify
the commissioner and we can use that
later yeah so I think we should do this
because this is clearly an area of
concern that should not be left un
addressed all right is there does the
any further
discussion move to uh recommend they
file a letter so it's an understanding
that even jalkar agrees that all the
rules those Incorporated by reference
are rules and need to be followed second
okay any further
discussion all right those in favor
favor I
opposed all right please send that
letter and uh will it we are interested
in seeing what the Dr chooses to reply
um and if the committee would like I
could also when I send it talk with uh
revenues councel if you wanted to
include this on the next month's agenda
just have them come in and maybe give a
brief update on what action they've
taken to address the issue uh we love to
hear from them once they've done that
but I yes any any response from the
commissioner or the Dr would be very
useful
okay all right that's the last agenda
item is there any further
business we will of course cancel the
continued meeting since there doesn't
seem to be any need for it there is
nothing else all right thank you in that
case we are
adjourned e